Holy kutch, what is wrong with you?
Right now, that is reality setting in on
somebody who did not pay attention for
the past 2 hours and they're realizing
that they [__] up doing it. He only
sees that he's getting an audience, that
he's getting clout from this connection
and he will defend anything and he
doesn't care to look into whatever it
is. That's sick. This guy is
sick, man.
>> [music]
>> Okay, so what happened is Connor and
Destiny had their crash show. Connor
said that he hates playing with the
groper's wife and they had this whole
fight and all this, right?
Connor you come to find out that the
guy, the devil guy, the thing he told
Connor was that this woman, his his
wife, his ex-wife, whatever, was doing
some sort of age play where they she
involved the
right? They were step parents like doing
something to the
And Connor asked the wife about it and
the wife said, "No, the husband's just
husband's just making it up cuz he like
wants to win in a breakup or he's mad
and all of this and he's making it up."
So, Connor went on his merry way like
told Destiny, "You shouldn't engage with
these kinds of people anymore. They
obviously have some problems and it's
really bad, right?" It seems like the
allegation has come out that now Destiny
got pictures of this guy's too, which is
crazy back in
like I assume November before, all
right?
But come to like this month
Connor realizes that Destiny is still
texting this woman, the woman who he
thought was just doing age play with
him, some sort of babysitter, right? And
then Connor finds out that this woman
wrote into Mr. Girl
and discussed like explicitly not not
just age play, not just babysitter
stuff, but fantasizing about being the
step parents of each other's and
involving the in the role play, okay?
And that changed Connor's mind basically
immediately. Once he found out that that
was the allegation, that the allegation
was true and that Destiny had continued
to engage with this woman after Connor
had called him out for it. And so that's
like the quick rundown of why Connor was
so upset, why he felt the need to go
public with a bunch of this stuff. All
right, without further ado, we might go
into the Hutch thing cuz that seems to
be where the content is.
Uh Hutch bot right here, let's get it
going.
Let's get it going.
>> I think there's hopefully
um a soul
or human being
that is capable of
>> [snorts]
>> redemption, kindness,
care, love.
Somewhere in there.
It's deeply buried under all of the
[__]
But there's flashes of that.
And I'm praying that eventually the
flashes
of his kindness and grace
and virtues, although he has many vices,
um I'm hoping one day he'll choose
to embrace his virtues and expand upon
them.
>> What's your analysis so far?
Um
>> This is Mr. Girl levels of crazy.
>> It's hard to take these comments as
sincere
when
you add the element of the fact that
it's being live streamed.
>> Why? Why?
>> You know, like making a spectacle of it.
It just really
>> These people knew each other primarily
these live streamers.
Connor's reputation as a live streamer
is being undermined significantly.
>> Really undercuts the tone. Like if he
was saying these things privately to to
Destiny.
>> He said them privately.
>> And if they had the kind of friendship
where that sort of talk was where they
had a rapport where that kind of talk
could happen and and that and it would
be like organic.
And uh like within the within the
boundaries of their friendship. But you
know,
making a making a spectacle of it.
>> I
I don't know why Hutch makes he he
literally makes a job out of coming in
uninformed and being told what happened
and like really up the analysis. Like
you probably shouldn't be stepping into
this at all. If you just don't care,
shut the [__] up. If you're going to go
and do this and it's like actually
serious for these people,
have a little concern and look into it.
Like don't get things fundamentally
wrong, foundationally wrong from the
outset just because some people were
mean to you. I am mean to Hutch because
he's a [__] Yeah, I see you. I see you
looking into my soul Hutch right now. I
see you. Eyes right here, buddy. Okay,
you're a
because you refuse to do any work for
your job. You are a lazy loser who shows
up uninformed and then actually reacts
to stuff or or talks about stuff that's
important and totally it up. Now, are
your really consequential in the grand
scheme of the universe? No.
But they're a lot worse than a lot of
other people's and they're all within my
space. So, I do dislike this guy. I
don't understand how he lets my dislike
for him chase him into being a [__]
like a total puppet for other people.
Why not just watch the content, figure
out what's going on and form an opinion
instead of just saying things like, "Oh
well, well, this should have been done
in private." Yeah, it was, idiot.
>> Comes across as kind of cynical, which
is a bit ironic because he's accusing
others of of uh
leveraging
Destiny for clout, you know.
So,
and it and it sounds like
he's convinced himself that this is like
a loving act of friendship, but again,
it's the same sort of commentary as the
last one, which is
these these conversations are
>> Wait, he did watch
Connor say that he brought this up in
private already, right?
I believe.
So, it's not even that he hasn't seen
it.
>> you know what I mean?
Uh
It's not normally how these kind of
friendships go.
These kinds of exchanges go. Which
brings [clears throat] us to food shops.
So, since
I
was pretty open about Steven's
>> No, I'm saying he watched some of the
previous conversations, ogre boy, and he
would know from the previous
conversations that Hutch has brought it
up in private Sorry, that Conner has
brought it up in private, because he
watched the previous conversations.
>> sins
But my beef with food shops 2 years ago,
my beef with food shops 3 years ago, my
beef with food shops 6 months ago, my
beef with food shops 2 months ago, my
beef with food shops now is that she is
an unrepentant all that.
She looks at
>> Um
He's been reading into her, but that
seems to be it. Food shops essentially
became his Jstock. Food shops had 1,700
people watching.
Uh gotcha. Okay. Okay. Cartoon drawings
of adolescents and she listens to it.
This has always made me uncomfortable.
I have
>> Okay, so we just got a face. We've got a
face. All right, we've got a face.
>> always just like this.
Food shops joked about suing me. She is
welcome to do so.
I will hire the cheapest attorney that I
can possibly find in order to respond to
the motions, and I will show up to
court, and I will play her own live
streams for the court to hear.
She is a I'm confused. What's happening?
>> What else is he doing? What is he
confused by? What else is going on? I
watched him just make a face. He sat
there with a stupid face on for 30
seconds, and he goes
Wait, what's happening?
>> ago, my beef with food shops 6
>> Dude, he is My god, he is a parody of
himself. It's like he's becoming dumber
and making stupider faces as we go
along. Like as time goes forward, he
gets
more dumb and makes dumber faces every
single time.
>> months ago, my beef with food shops 2
months ago, my beef with food shops now
is that she is an unrepentant
She looks at cartoon drawings of
adolescents and she listens to
This has always made me uncomfortable.
I have always disliked this.
Food shops joked about suing me. She is
welcome to do so.
I will hire the cheapest attorney that I
can possibly find in order to respond to
the motions and I will show up to court
and I will play her own live streams for
the court to hear.
She is unrepentant.
>> People are like, "Oh, the court won't
allow that evidence." I don't understand
why why would the court not allow her
statements onto the record?
>> There are dozens of clips of her
admitting to this behavior.
>> Okay.
>> So.
>> You heard it twice now, Hutch. So, go
ahead, say it loud and proud. Do you
support this
or not?
>> I'm not a fan that Steven chose as his
champion.
A
who thought the adolescent was
Now, breaking this down a little bit
further because there will be liberals
who watch this stream.
>> So, did he say he didn't understand and
now does he understand and he's going to
let it go by without speaking or
>> I do not believe in the Max Carson quote
of you can fantasize about whatever you
want.
Your brain,
like a vital organ or a muscle, responds
to
>> Don't have her babysit your kids.
Dude, what? Dude, he's just talking
about everyone's bad deeds so he doesn't
have to think about his divorce. Dude, I
don't even.
It's actually crazy watching It's crazy
watching like the chat won't even engage
with this, right?
Even a Not even a little bit.
>> And there's a concept that I explained
to Chud Logic several years ago called
neuroplasticity. It basically means
>> He just paused so he listened to
something, heard Connor call this person
a
said, "I didn't quite get that." Went
back about 50 seconds, replayed the same
segment, and did not give a take.
That's like only Hutch could do that.
Nobody else in this business is ever
doing that. To watch almost a full
minute of content from somebody, pause
so you didn't really pay attention, roll
back that full minute, watch the whole
thing, and not even think, oh, I should
give a take on this.
>> Um, I went to bed, uh, as I do, 10:00
p.m., Netflix and my programs, and
and, uh, I opened up my phone and
checked YouTube real quick, and there
was like a thumbnail of a streamer that
was talking about Livin' Learn drama,
some debate. And I listened to the
stream, and, uh,
FoodChops was defending me, or whatever,
and, uh,
I didn't know anything about FoodChops,
like, you know what? Why don't I
call into the stream? And so, that's
what I did. I called into the stream. We
had a little
>> His YouTube title was Hutch Defense
Squad. So, he was like name searching
himself.
And saw Hutch Defense Squad, and hopped
onto the stream.
>> conversation. And, uh, I didn't I have I
had no idea about like
FoodChops'
consumption, or, uh, anything, you know,
uh, she seemed pretty harmless, and, uh,
nice and all.
>> You had no idea, but then you were
informed, obviously.
>> me for a clip. She asked me would I ever
would I ever associate with Destiny ever
again?
And I paused for a minute, and I said,
you know I mean, sure. I mean, I would
like leave the door open for literally
anybody. And that was like that was like
the gist of it. And then that like
started a whole thing.
Destiny had called in before then. Are
you sure about that? [laughter]
Are you positive about that?
>> He's like the dumbest man anywhere in
this sphere. It's so funny.
Like, I I feel like I should do, if I
wanted to commit,
I don't, but if I did, I'd just do a
drinking game, where I take like a tenth
of an ounce of alcohol every time Hutch
is confused on one of his live streams.
I would die by the 30-minute mark.
I'd have taken like like a tenth of a
shot every time. I'd have taken like by
the 30-minute mark, you got to figure
300 shots?
>> All that, I don't know if they had any
contact
before then. I don't actually know, but
I I'm pretty sure that's how FoodChop,
FoodChops, I think that's the origin
story there.
And I talked to this gentleman, whose
current profile on Discord is called
Devil. They engaged in step-parent
role-play.
>> Um, FYI, this Devil guy comes on stream
later, and walks all of this [__] back
in front of him, by the way. So, this is
a lie. Yeah, no spoilers. Why Why
spoilers in the chat?
>> Also, that's not true. That's like a
lie, but Hutch probably because Hutch
doesn't trust his own internal thought
process because Hutch is like he can't
really put like connect dots himself. He
might just take that and run with it for
the rest of the stream.
Right?
Like
like I'm not joking that he doesn't
really trust himself to identify what's
happening. And so the chat telling him
that may actually push him in that
direction immediately.
>> That's the clip that I saw.
>> I saw that clip making the rounds.
>> That they sent pictures of the family,
specific details unknown.
That he was deeply deeply deeply upset
by this.
That he wanted vengeance against Steven.
Now, in the text message logs, what I
remember is that he was accusing this
person, his wife, of engaging in step
parent role play. Of involving pictures
of their
of engaging in lurid affair or depending
on your definition,
role play and how that was repulsive and
disgusting and he hated her and hated
Steven for doing this and destroying his
family. So, to Wick
to Hutch
to
people
>> Why am I involved in this? Hang on. Why
is my name coming up right now?
>> My Twitter might have gotten hacked, by
the way. My Twitter has already been
banned once.
So, I'm paying
a price
>> Uh-oh.
>> for telling the truth, the whole truth
and nothing but the truth, so help me
God, as I've seen it, as I remember it.
I decide, "Hey,
I gave him a shot across the bow.
I can't tell who's telling the truth. I
don't know if Steven is being
>> Let it go.
>> And if he's pretending to be a year old
getting
by a year old girl, which is weird.
>> Did he just say
>> So,
I decide, "Hey,
I gave
>> Did he just say we got more faces coming
[laughter] out?
>> So,
I decide, "Hey,
I gave him a shot across the bow.
I can't tell who's telling the truth. I
don't know if Steven is being a [__]
And if he's pretending to be a year old
boy getting by a year old girl, which is
weird. But Steven's a weird guy, so
whatever. Or if it's worse.
So I'm going to put this in I'm going to
give Steven a shot across the bow. I'm
going to ask the husband what he wants
to do. Look, Connor's claiming that that
he
Did he see evidence of this or
Is Connor saying that that's what
happened? No, Connor is saying that the
husband said this to him, but the wife
says no.
And so he's going to say to Steven,
"Hey, how about you stop engaging with
people who are doing this who are like
telling me about it or crashing out in
in public about this?
How about you just don't do that
anymore?
Cuz it's it's actually like kind of
weird.
Right? So Connor doesn't expect that
it's real cuz one of the two parties is
saying, "No, we broke up and like he's
losing it and it's whatever."
So he goes, "Oh, well, it's a domestic.
Okay, I I'm probably not going to pay
that much attention."
This is just off the top of my head
though.
I have my own judgments, but they're
they're just I don't I would never
Like it's all very messy for me. I I'm
in my settling down years, so I look at
that and I think, "Well, that looks
pretty noisy."
You know? But I don't lose sleep
You don't think about it. You don't care
about it, which is which makes your
commentary here like abhorrent. It makes
it gross.
You don't care to be informed. You don't
want to be informed. If you don't want
to be informed, then sit the [__] down
and shut the [__] up.
It's so
simple. You know why I don't talk about
the genocide in Sudan?
Cuz I don't know about the genocide in
Sudan.
I'm not going to take a strong position
on it when I got no idea what the [__]
is going on.
Sleep over it. I don't think about it
basically ever.
Unless I'm watching a video like this
and I'm forced to learn things about
Steven's life that, you know, I would
have preferred to not know cuz I just
don't care.
Like I have opinions about it, but I
don't like
think about it. It's not something that
takes up any kind of real estate in my
mind.
And Connor Connor seems to be saying
that you know, me and Wicker being
obtuse because the you know, Steven's
like personal life is is what the
snarkers talk about a lot. Well, that's
isn't that like our point?
Like why are they
so focused on this guy's
interpersonal relationships and like
romantic life?
>> Because he fans and co-workers and has
done a lot of harm to those co-workers
and instead of admitting fault and
trying to make like give reparations or
try to make amends, he has decided to
like try to break them off of the
internet instead.
You said you knew Pixie. You said you'd
hung out with Pixie at some point. I
assume you knew some of these people. I
assume you give a [__] about those
people being hurt and possibly getting
some form of justice. If not through the
courts, then just literally somebody
apologizing for wronging them. No?
Well, no, cuz you you claimed that well,
you couldn't get back with Destiny until
he'd shown some remorse and he's shown
no remorse and you're hanging out with
him again cuz you're a you can't stand
on your own and you'll always be a [__]
a stupid unfortunately who has to suck
to make money. A stupid dumb I shouldn't
say actually.
>> This conduct is not private.
It is not.
We found out about Melina and Lauren
Southern and Rose because Steven sent
his not only home made to Rose.
He sent his love letters to and from
Lauren Southern.
Why are you sending love letters of you
and your ex-girlfriend to a worker you
have known for 10 days?
If Steven's private life was private,
then it would remain private. If
Steven's personal life was personal, it
would remain personal. But it's
>> Why is he saying twerker? What does he
mean by that?
So, when Steven was getting catfished,
the pretense was that Rose was a
twerker? Wait, what? Was an only fans
model? Actually not. And the same level
of indiscretion that he engaged with in
reference to Rose. Are only fans models
considered twerkers?
>> Uh one, yes, and two, this person is a
hutch mod obviously a DG G area. Oh,
there she was an OF model. No, she
wasn't.
No, she wasn't.
Selling on Twitter not OF at hutch. They
always do this. They always just do it.
It's so funny man.
It's so funny and it it might seem small
but it's not in aggregate. It builds up
to something.
>> Wouldn't twerkers be if you're a chud?
You know what? Let's ask Claude. No, you
know what? Let's not ask Claude. Let's
uh skip forward in the video.
>> Not only that
but her and her husband are broken up
obviously.
But Steven thought it was prudent
to receive
of the husband
and this wife.
I want you to understand that.
Britt vacillates between endless
adoration and love for Steven. She truly
loves him on a fundamental level. She
thinks he's the best thing since sliced
bread.
Her husband has blamed Steven for the
implosion of his family.
Steven received a
video of these two mentally unstable
homicidal and
military veterans having for his
personal enjoyment.
That is something that I was told on
Saturday and by the way, that was
confirmed by both parties.
>> What's the significance of them being
military veterans? Wait, what?
>> Just
It is a little funny that Connor
highlights that. I think it's just to
underscore how mentally they might be to
be honest with you which is a little
weird given Connor's a military veteran
but
>> husband has blamed Steven for the
implosion of his family.
>> Keep going.
>> Um like okay. So my understanding is
that a lot of these allegations get kind
of blown up later in the stream
by one of the parties that he's talking
about here.
>> Is that your understanding? Is that what
a chatter told you 30 seconds ago?
>> Um
>> Well, probably like 30 minutes ago now.
>> I question the ethics of like let's say
it was all real, you know, let's say all
of this was real.
I question the ethics of like let's say
that these they're they're a couple,
they're two veterans, They have PTSD.
They have
self-unaliving thoughts, this kind of
thing.
Why would you blast this out in a live
stream?
>> Because he's having his like own
reputation maligned.
Right? That he was concerned about this
and he's basically being told by a bunch
of people around him, like this is his
job and his job is being undermined by
people saying he's lying and he's going,
"Well, the truth will will set you free
and this is the truth."
Right?
He's basically been accused of lying
like multiple times.
You could say, "Oh, well, none of this
should have been made public." But I do
think he's actually concerned about
several different things here. One of
them is his own concern, but I don't
think his own concern like is
significantly
him having his own concern here, it's
not like he can't defend his own
business, right?
Like I don't think that's fair to say,
"Well, actually, you need to just roll
over and die cuz these people are
willing to lie and call you a liar. So,
roll over and die, Connor." I just don't
think that's appropriate.
>> Why would you do that? If that if that
was actually true?
If if that was true, wouldn't blasting
out their personal business on a live
stream like that potentially be a pretty
significant risk to those people if all
that was true?
It just
seems wildly inappropriate.
>> So,
I'm going to guess that Connor's going
to say
that this seems to be downstream of
these people crashing out taking
everybody around Destiny in November
when Connor originally sends him the
letter, right? That Destiny continuing
that relationship means that it will
continue to come up again and again and
again and Destiny's the person putting
them in the limelight. And that's what
he's upset about.
And for Connor, I'm guessing there's
some added elements of like, "Well, if
this is just going to keep happening,
I'm going to I'm going to talk about it
now."
And I do understand this for some
people. It's like
you want to let the person who lies and
uses people in this way continuously be
the victor because he's willing to lie
and keep everything like he's willing to
weaponize their their privacy like
concerns about their privacy,
no matter what happens, right?
I do get it. I I get how people get into
that headspace.
Anyway, we we keep going. I I get how
people get into the headspace even if I
might disagree with, you know,
I it's it's a tough one, man. The The
thing makes this whole thing tough.
>> That is something that I was told on
Saturday, and by the way, that was
confirmed by both parties.
That was confirmed by Brett, and that
was confirmed by Devil. So,
you can imagine,
I hope,
my frustration, rage, and anger
that my
friend
who is $800,000 down because he was
imprudent
is still being imprudent
in a way that could get him
and in a way that could result in a
woman's
I'm He doesn't understand the
contradiction here?
His
So, there could even be a contradiction
here. Like, I I understand what Connor's
talking about, but there could even be a
contradiction here, right?
There could be, but unfortunately,
Connor basically
defended Destiny when this pattern
played out the last time.
And now, he's asked Destiny, "I defended
you here cuz I think you're a good
person, and I think ultimately we could
be better than this, and you could be
better than this, and you can make your
whole thing work." And then Destiny
immediately engaged in the same pattern
again, right? That's That's his problem.
And so, he might think that, well,
actually sweeping this under the rug
doesn't really do anything good. It's
just going to lead to this happening
again, and again, and again, and again,
and again.
I
And the sad thing is is the person who
gets hurt hurt least in all of these
different instances seems to be Destiny.
You see a friend who's doing these
self-destructive behaviors that always
burn somebody significantly more than
they burn him.
I do understand why you having defended
that at some point makes you feel like
defending it in the future would be bad,
or even keeping it under wraps in the
future would be bad.
>> So, his whole line of attack here is
implying that Steven's actions
put someone at risk. Put somebody
mentally unstable at risk.
And then just like blast all the But he
doesn't understand the contradiction of
like blasting all of this out on a live
stream?
The Snarkers have given me one thing
and one thing alone.
I have verified that this is Britt
through information
that I have saved.
She wrote in to Mr. Girl's call-in show
via email to discuss her relationship
with Steven.
>> when he plays it?
>> This is confirmed.
I cannot be sued for this
because I have the evidence that backs
up the truth of this scenario.
Let's listen.
>> Okay, I would have to skip through some
of this.
>> Oh, wait. No.
>> in an online affair with a guy for
almost a year. My husband wouldn't
engage with any of the weird
trauma-induced kink stuff that I was
curious about, and so I was compelled to
impulsively and regrettably regrettably
engage with this guy online in some
pretty intense and taboo age play
scenarios, including fantasizing about
being step parents to each other's
and obviously
>> This is Mr. Girl reading it. Gotcha.
Tahaj, thank you so much for the tier
one membership. Appreciate it.
>> Obviously it went way too far, but felt
really intensely good in the moment. But
afterward, I felt sick and
>> I mean, asked the question of like
whether or not the Snarkers were running
gayops in Connor's chat.
Uh, I don't know how much I can say.
But the answer is yes, that was
happening quite clearly, explicitly.
Yes.
>> and cried all night because
>> What were the gayops in Connor's chat?
I
Dude, Hutch, define gayop. Define gayop
right now.
>> If you're saying that you doubt your
willingness to hold boundaries in real
life, then that is dangerous. Yes.
>> The all caps just got
>> I feel like I'm reading um
Kevin Spacey
>> Is it Are you really He Hutch just heard
that this person is considering letting
a
partner violate her
and Hutch is like, "Oh my god, are these
all caps? Does this guy type in caps
lock in MS Paint?"
I don't want to undersell how psychotic
this is that Connor did his manifesto
here in MS Paint. I don't want to
undersell how psychotic that is. But
still, this is like the most important
part of the stream right now and Hutch
is not paying attention intentionally.
I'm positive it's because he got told it
was going to get walked back.
That somebody in chat said, "Well,
actually, it's going to get walked back
here." And Hutch just blanked. He just
blanked. He doesn't care. He's not going
to pay attention to anything else.
>> Basically, these notes that they find at
the
>> Seven No, that's me. I have eaten
foliage with $5. Amazing Connor didn't
consider Britt could have told that tale
to both her husband and this letter and
therefore not really corroborated. I
don't really think I understand that.
Cybex with $5. I will assume none of
this is walked back and it's none of my
business what two consenting adults do
privately.
As far as people's now, I'm not saying
that
this is
what actually occurred, but as far as
what two consenting adults do in terms
of role play stuff, I have
zero opinion on that stuff. I I don't
understand the relevance at all.
It could be the wildest role play you
could possibly imagine.
And I just I don't think that's any of
my business. Uh, you know, like there's
some kinks where I'm like, that's a
little weird, but I you know, I And if
there's things that like in the past
people have like
asked me to do things that I wasn't
comfortable with, but I just don't I
just don't care. I just I don't think
Again, is he just not going to engage?
He's just not going to engage at all.
So, I also sent a DM here, but
>> The all caps just uh
I mean, to both her husband and this
letter and therefore not really
corroborated. I don't really think I
understand that. Cybex with $5. I will
assume none of this is walked back and
it's none of my business what two
consenting adults do privately.
As far as people's now, I'm not saying
that
>> Do we
Do we not listen to what was just said?
This is actually crazy, man.
>> This is
what actually occurred, but as far as
what two adults do in terms of role play
stuff, I have
zero opinion on that stuff. I don't
understand the relevance at all.
It could be the wildest role play you
could possibly imagine.
And I
>> Question for Hutch.
Do you think the role play is the most
concerning part of this story? Reading
or listening comprehension question. Is
the role play an important part of this
story?
>> I just
>> I don't think that's any of my business.
Uh you know, like there's some kinks
where I'm like, that's a little weird,
but I you know, I and if there's things
that like in the past people have like
asked me to do things that I wasn't
comfortable with, but I just don't I
just don't care. I just I don't think
that that that that it's relevant
to any kind of like discussion about
someone's character.
I just don't care. People are into weird
stuff, man. You just everybody's
everybody's got their weird stuff that
they're into.
And I do not give if
>> And yes, my outline is on Microsoft
Paint.
Because [__] you, that's why.
>> He 1,000% accidentally that he did not
mean to do that.
>> willingness to hold down
>> He pulls it up earlier in the stream and
shows it. It reads from it.
>> in real life, then that is dangerous.
Yes.
>> Dude, this
>> I man, I don't
I don't know what the [__] to say at
this point.
Like honestly, if you're dealing with
allegations, like some allegation that
somebody would let someone
to not pay attention and then just go,
"Oh my god, Connor's doling caps."
That seems totally absurd. That seems
like this is something you probably
shouldn't touch. If this is the level of
engagement you're going to give, if this
is the effort you're going to put in,
holy Hutch, what is wrong with you? What
is your problem, man?
>> Okay.
And yeah.
>> Listen, when two consenting adults want
to discuss the concept of letting the
other adult [__]
Well, I got no problem with that." says
Hutch, quote Hutch.
Wow, that's really cool, Hutch. Seems a
little [__] up for you to say that.
That's just a little [__] up. Me
personally, I'm like, "Hey, if
somebody's talking about how turned on
they are by the idea of letting another
adult
like harm their
>> I hate it too, Jerry. Yeah, I think it's
it's gross.
>> neutral
or positive to engage in a kink
or roleplay.
I think it's bad.
>> Well, there we go.
>> it's neutral or good
and you are a current member of my
community, I ask one of two things from
you.
Why are we exploring the morality of
kinks? You either keep that opinion to
yourself
or you leave my community.
>> You down to hang out with people who do
roleplay there, Hutch? That involves
like actual real
Like as in they are the object of the
fantasy.
Like cuz, you know, I'm not exactly
I'm not like a kink shamer, but it does
feel like it's really out of balance.
Like, okay, you need to do something
crazy like that. Two two consenting
adults and all that, but just make it
about somebody made up. Just make it
about something You know what I'm
saying? Like don't don't put a real
person into it, dude.
>> And if
let's say that all of my oilers,
all of my chippers, all of my community
support come from people
who think this is not a big deal.
>> Hutch can now purge a bunch of mods and
followers from this drama.
>> Yeah, I I I said it the last time. This
is This is kind of the text book
definition of a uh
a crash out, but this one seems a bit
prolonged.
>> And who think that it is perfectly sane
and rational for Steven to be
s-
and hostile people while currently being
sued for sexual misconduct.
>> PJ with $5, I guess I sort of know what
he's trying to get at, but it also feels
like he's getting lazy and just
infantilizing people with mental
illness. I he's certainly doing that.
>> I don't want your money.
I would rather destroy my streaming
career
and I would rather go back to working
construction administration as a nobody
who participates in this space as a
hobby
than continue to rely on your viewership
or financial support.
I want that to be abundantly clear.
>> Thanks with the $2. Pretty sure Connor's
having a mental breakdown. I don't know.
A mental breakdown is Maybe that's a bit
strong the language. He's having what we
might call an episode. He's in it.
>> Dude.
>> [laughter]
>> He's like in it right now.
>> That's pretty crazy. That's pretty
crazy.
Uh but I still maintain like if he if he
just
backed off a little bit, took a break,
decompressed for a little bit, maybe got
some couch time,
talked to a therapist or himself, then
um
like it shouldn't be career ending, you
know what I mean?
>> That if you thought that I should have
swept for this, if you thought that I
should have let sleeping dogs lie, if
you think this is some kind of crash
out, I would like you to go to the
Discord. I would like you to click one
of the settings buttons.
>> I just like Dude, it's it's pretty funny
watching a lot of people just dance
around this stuff. Like they just
totally dance around it.
>> And I will not be gaslit by moral
cowards.
>> We keep watching.
>> into other perspectives.
Specifically,
thank you Hutch. Thank you Wick. Why is
this all in the open? I don't know. Why
the [__] do I know about it?
Why do If this is Steven's personal
life,
if this is his private life, and his
private life is private,
even open. I don't know. Why the [__] do
I know about it?
Why do I
If
>> Connor makes good points. Connor, how
did Connor know about Destiny private
life?
I had not considered this.
Huh.
>> This is Steven's personal life.
If this is his private life, and his
private life is private,
why do I know about it?
Is it because he recklessly engaged with
mentally ill people who contacted me and
told me about it?
Is that why?
>> In private, right?
Do they consent to you talking about
>> No, in public, you Oh,
I I'm so lucky I said there instead of
something else. I was so close.
>> Public uh fresh paycheck with $5. If
Destiny wants to [__] his own life up,
that's his prerogative.
>> They have dragged this out in public
multiple times now, Hutch.
>> It's all over Connor is using that.
>> In fact, allow me to pull up one of the
examples of it being brought up in
public.
Here's the husband. For those who don't
know, Destiny's been having an affair
with a married woman with his girlfriend
broke up with him and threatened to
expose him as a pedo. She had was
sending him pics of her
This is the wife. I have proof. It was
my wife. We're split up now. That's why
blank or whatever her name is left him.
They were doing weird H play stuff and
she sent him pics of my kids. No BH, I
don't know what that is. She's been in
here, Brit. Delete the pictures of my
off your computer, you sick freak.
Destiny solicits pictures of from
mentally ill housewives he made a blitz
and I have proof. Acknowledge me, freak.
Pedo cult. Wow.
Wow.
This is in public. This is in public in
November of 2025.
Why is it in public? Well,
>> as a reason to condemn him.
That's a level of personal involvement
that is uh not healthy, I would say.
Lawson with $5 Connor bless his heart
saying
>> I think this is what's unhealthy. This
like weird cultish lack of engagement.
You don't know the facts of what's
happening. This is what's unhealthy,
Hutch.
You are justifying not paying attention.
You're somehow justifying to yourself.
You're not paying attention and there
are actual like there's actual
problematic behavior here. Possibly not
even from Destiny. That's the sad thing.
You could run into a scenario here where
you could almost entirely make Destiny
blameless. But instead of actually
engaging and figuring out what's going
wrong, you are just telling everybody
else they're weird for caring while
spending hours of your day reviewing
this vod.
>> It is also
not a crazy stance to say that Steven
has over his friends, people who care
about him, and his professional
relationships. Peace going him, we're
going to do a show together in 2024. He
[__] that up. Hutch, Josiah, IRI, me,
Lonerbox, we would all love to
collaborate with Steven. He is a nuclear
stockpile next to a case of dynamite.
>> So, you just draw boundaries around that
stuff and live your life, you know?
>> But you haven't drawn a boundary, Hutch.
You're reacting to his personal life
stuff right now. You haven't drawn a
boundary.
You're drawing the personal stuff in is
in your boundary. You're commenting on
it right now, which is particularly
egregious cuz you don't realize this
somehow.
Somehow you don't realize you've put
yourself inside the personal life drama.
You are commenting. You're as parasocial
or weird as Counter Points.
But you're also blinding yourself
intentionally.
So, like it's one thing to say, you
know, somebody is really traumatic in a
parking lot and they say, "This person
might" It's one thing for you to go,
"That's none of my business. I'm sorry.
Call the cops."
But if you start listening and you go,
"No, no, no, no, no, no. It's really
weird that you're talking about this in
public. Hey, no. Hey, lady, shut the
[__] up. It's weird you're talking about
this in public right now. Hey, lady,
lady, shut the [__] up." And she goes,
"No, look at the evidence." And And she
don't look at the evidence. She just
goes, "Weird for you to be talking about
this, [__] Hey, [__] it's weird for
you to be talking about this right now."
That's like what we're experiencing,
right? He is not looking at what's
happening. He is quite literally telling
people who are aware of the situation
that they should not be talking about it
without actually learning the facts of
the matter.
>> Isn't role-playing as the step-parents
of each other just role-playing as being
married? How is that inappropriate?
Well, when you [__]
the
When you [__] the it's inappropriate.
Right?
There's no way he just sits here and
makes
faces when it's being laid out directly.
Right?
Real serious.
>> [sighs]
>> This year.
This is Britney.
Is he like on his phone?
Writing into Mr. Girl.
>> I was involved in an online affair with
a guy for almost a year.
My husband wouldn't engage with any of
the weird trauma induced
>> Okay.
Um
and
>> kink stuff that I was curious about and
so I was compelled to impulsively and
regrettably
>> Guy's sick.
>> regretfully engage with this guy online
in some pretty intense and taboo age
play scenarios including fantasizing
about being step parents to each other's
and obviously it went way too far but
felt really intensely good in the
moment. But afterward I felt sick and
cried all night.
>> But that doesn't say anything about
though. Am I crazy? Wasn't that just we
were step
step parents to each other's
When did it involve like
pretending like they were
>> This is Britney.
>> This might be close to engagement. Maybe
could be close to engagement. Maybe
maybe maybe.
>> Writing into Mr. Girl.
>> Maybe.
>> I was involved in an online affair with
a guy for almost a year.
My husband wouldn't engage with any of
the weird trauma induced kink stuff that
I was curious about. And so, I was
compelled to impulsively and regrettably
regretfully engage with this guy online
in some pretty intense and taboo age
play scenarios, including fantasizing
about being step parents to each other's
>> kink
>> including fantasizing about being step
parents to each other's
>> And obviously, it went way too far, but
felt
>> That's not
If you're both step parents, then you're
not like pretending like you're
or whatever, right?
>> Dude. Dude.
>> I'm sorry. At this point, it's like Like
and again,
I don't know how else to say it. I've
said it so many times in the same way.
If he listened and he went, "You know
what? That's gross, but like I'm still
not going to say unless it can get her,
I'm still not going to say." Like if he
actually engaged, but he is he is
intentionally blinding himself.
He's intentionally not understanding.
When they say, "And obviously, it went
way too far." What else would that mean?
Nothing else. It is incredibly specific
and clear what is meant here, and Hutch
is pretending he can't understand.
>> Media literate
>> Is he Is he going to
>> Good media literacy. Real serious.
>> I'm sure they threw up from imagining
getting married and having sex with
another adult. You're doing great.
>> Any thoughts?
>> king.
>> Good analysis.
>> Any thoughts?
>> Right, because it obviously felt real
bad, too.
How do you know if the other person also
feels the same way or if they would
actually do it? My
>> Do what?
There's nothing wrong here. It's just
two consensual adults talking about
having sex with each other.
>> It's pig-latin. Is he like about to
start crying? Is he about to start
crying? I feel like
>> What Why is she talking about being
worried that the other person might do
something.
>> And now, at minimum, I do think that is
the face of somebody who wishes they'd
paid attention for the past 2 hours. I
do think Listen, he's going to get back
to sweeping, I'm positive, but right
now, that is that is reality setting in
on somebody who did not pay attention
for the past 2 hours, and they're
realizing that they [__] up doing it.
Uh dude,
that's that's crazy. He's going to go
back to sweeping, I'm positive. He'll
you know, he'll he'll he'll get through
this really fast.
But it's when it's laid out that slowly,
I very much hope he's got no way to
wiggle out of trying to understand
what's going on here.
>> She's just talking about them being
married and engaging in normal
consensual adult She's not She's
obviously not talking about
>> understanding is the best predictors
are drug use
and low empathy.
>> Uh and even worse, what if you felt like
you love them so much that you wouldn't
care if they did, and you get off on
what you would potentially be willing to
allow them to get away with?
>> Oh, clearly. They're just talking about
consensual adult sex.
Real serious.
Are you serious?
>> I swear if he doesn't engage during
this, I'm
Say something.
>> That's
crazy pants.
>> Say something.
>> proof of the Destiny's
No.
I have the testimony of the husband.
>> Okay, like right? Like actual Like
actual
I'm sorry. If you will not speak after
that, you will not say that you
understand, you just were downplaying
this, you said it was nothing, and now
it's been laid out for you so slowly,
and you're still going to pretend you
don't understand what the allegation is.
By the way, you could hear all this, So,
could still go, "Well, that doesn't
prove Destiny did anything."
You could still say that.
But, you are you are denying what is in
front of your face in a way that is
incredibly concerning, man.
Holy [__]
>> I have the testimony of the wife. I have
the wife writing into Mr. Girl.
That's what I have. How do you know for
sure that he intentionally abuses
mentally ill women? It's probably not
even intentional. It's probably
compulsive.
If Steven had explicitly told you he was
going to do what he was going to do and
leave him alone if you don't like it,
would you have come public with this
regardless? Probably.
If If it were true that Steven were
compulsively engaging in uh was
compulsively engaging in um
promiscuous behavior with
with other people, then then like both
parties would be dealing with mental
illness in that spot. It's not just
about like
>> Dude, he totally he totally ignores it.
He totally just ignores
That's sick.
This guy is
sick, man.
sick. I'm telling you, this is the guy
who
Uh no, I
Dude, I
I probably should just stop engaging
with this dude's [__] at all at this
point. This guy is a sick
And by the way, that's without You could
have Destiny be totally innocent of
everything here.
And it doesn't excuse what this stream
is at all. It actually doesn't excuse it
in any way. Like it it it's actually
divorced now from what the reality of
the Destiny situation is. He only sees
that he's getting an audience, that he's
getting clout from this connection, and
he will defend anything. And he doesn't
care to look into whatever it is at all.
That's
ill, man. This guy is like fun
fundamentally foundationally
broken.